je voudrais qu'on ait une pensée
particulière pour ceux qui un jour n'ont
pas demandé à porter les croix qu'ils
ont dû porter à tous ces parents qui
portent des enfants qui sont différents
qui l'ont pas demandé mais qui l'ont
reçu Seigneur moi je veux te remercier
pour tous ces gens qui s'occupent des
autres des malades des petits des
vieillards ils sont fatigués et ben soit
leur force ils sont tristes soit leur
joie ils sont épuisés soit leur vitalité
amen
amen j'ai craqué encore une fois parce
que franccesca et est une petite fille
qui est lourdement handicapée mais je
réalise de plus en plus qu'elle l' pas
tant que son
handicapé que c'est moi qui éta
handicapé c'est moi qui s'handicape de
son handicap pourquoi que j'ai mis dans
ma tête que ma fille é une croix à
portter c'est les rôles qui sont
renversés parce que c'est elle qui me
porte
elle me porte à être une meilleure
personne dans